après des mois d'incertitude sur le
déroulement des manifestations pour
commémorer la révolution française le
restant président de la mission du
bicentenaire jean-noël janet a enfin pu
annoncer aujourd'hui le programme des
festivités et honig bonnet
d'entrée de jeu jean noël jeanneney
annonce la couleur tant sur le retard
qu'ils étaient pris dans l'organisation
du bicentenaire avant sa nomination que
sur les grands axes et les objectifs qui
ont guidé ses choix
chacun sait qu'un grand retard avait été
pris je n'épiloguerai pas là dessus j'ai
eu 24 heures pour angers mire et ensuite
il nous est revenu d'agir
quels principes mettons nous en sommes
au feu les ramasser en quelques phrases
d'abord la révolution appartient au
monde entier nous ne ferons pas une
commémoration propre aux centristes
nous ne serons pas du col qui n'est pas
question de rab ouvrir là l'héritage de
le re a fermé de le réduire
sur je ne sais quel plus petit commun
dénominateur d'un consensus supposé de
l'anper donc sur tous les plans ce
calendrier du bicentenaire avec dès la
nuit du 1er janvier 89 des montgolfières
dans tous les départements
le 21 mars 1er germinal et jour du
printemps les maires les écoliers
planteront large de la liberté dans leur
commune le 5 lundi sera la
reconstitution des états généraux à
versailles puis les faibles de la
fraternité à la fin de juin qui nous
mèneront à la grande célébration quatre
jours de fête nationale dont une soirée
jean michel jarre du 13 au 16 juillet et
la présence de nombreux chefs d'état
enfin le 26 août ce sera l'hommage du
monde entier à la déclaration des droits
de l'homme
un grand moment sur le